well deborah eden i'm not singing but
dancing on strictly a few years ago
oh look at you oh look at me there you
are and
i mean were you passionate about dancing
beforehand or did this suddenly wake up
this thing in you
no i mean i've always liked music so
i've always liked dancing but i mean
doing strictly is a way different thing
to dancing a bit at weddings
so um the lovely thing is i
my husband when i was doing strictly
paul could see how much i
loved her i mean loved i was i loved
doing strictly
and he secretly took dancing lessons oh
i know
i know so i know but that's the most
romantic
30 years i've been horrible to him for
30 years and then he goes and does that
and and and as a result of that
um he's grew to love dancing we both
loved dancing we went off to buenos
aires
learned how to do argentine tango
um and we now dance probably about four
hours a week whenever we can
so yeah we'll draw a veil there shall we
they dance for four hours a week
you know it's a lovely thing though
because we have busy life we all have
busy lives
and actually just being face to face
with your par you know but there's four
hours of
tweeting
four hours four hours face to face
sweating sweating
the rhythm
[Music]